just close your eyes until you're 29
just close your eyes into in 29
as you guys could see it was super
passionate I'll say it again
Monday morning super gloomy in New York
really trying to figure out how to show
you guys these meetings so this I want
you to start the vlog
Tyler period you could take care of the
rest you know I never imposed but
desperate to to figure out how to hack
in here so let me try to figure self so
first meeting was with Steve Babcock the
chief creative officer and Claude the
head of HR I'm just auditing the two
hundred people in the department who's
killing it think it's imperative to dig
deep and spend time with your a players
someone do more of that going into the
rest of my career and then talking about
who's struggling and making sure we're
giving them radical candor I think you
never want to be in a place where you
surprise people if they're struggling
and I think at times when you're good
peeps you kind of want to hold it in and
I think we do that in our real lives and
I think we do it in organizations and so
that's very much top of mine so I did
that then jumped into a meeting here
with Alan I was the CFO just getting the
updates to how August went what went
well what didn't go well
plenty did not go well plenty of
stresses this tone that you're feeling
for me comes from that as I'm processing
like how do I get better then fun things
happen like Andy Kay gets a new haircut
and it puts me in a good mood show them
those sides show me that fade Andy yeah
you know and so you know for all the the
headaches you get some awesome news like
in these new haircut it makes you feel
good headed to Amsterdam I don't know
what the Rock's doing this guy just
sitting there thinks he's fancy this is
how the place is run these days I guess
so
plenty of work to do everybody this is
Gary Vaynerchuk super pumped about my
trip to Singapore big shout out to slush
very excited about doing this QA let's
get into it
you know you know I think my biggest
mistakes have been the things that I
haven't done invest early and an uber
pass on TV shows that became monster
hits you know I'm just crippled by
opportunities so my mistakes are not I
did this I lost I came back up there
hidden mistakes which in a lot of ways
are even worse because you're always
wondering what if what if what if or or
mental strains you know you want to win
and you're always questioning like I
mean should have I started vaynermedia
like should have I gotten into my
family's business what I've gotten to
Silicon Valley you know in 1996 and made
a good trillion I don't know I mean it
all is what it is
I can't complain I don't dwell I hate
these questions to be very frank with
you because you're asking me to look
back and I think that's a fundamental
flaw it doesn't matter what my biggest
mistakes are it just matters what I do
with those things going forward and so
that's where I'm at peace go ahead
hey YouTube this is Colin very handsome
and very smart
Colin helps is basically my copywriter
ghostwriter of my current stuff stuff
Liam writes the books but for these
articles you've been seeing from medium
and gary mitrik calm this was a whole
new thing we're doing called crushing it
which is more him interviewing people
that are following the thing crushing at
the book coming out in January but my
blog posts he takes
content from the web starts the
framework pitches me the concepts that
like articles that we should be writing
based on what he's seeing in the
zeitgeist I say yes or no transcribes my
words into English asks me five to seven
questions to add more to it then reads
it back and then I change an adjective
or two here and make sure it's my voice
but that's how I scale with the
infrastructure desired and say 90% of
people won't be
this is what Cathy started the key
reason that people win in the 2017 flip
challenge like what does this hammer
work more than anything is the upfront
work and research babban didn't hear
that I have creators now and wants to
learn while they're here he was a
creator as a 12 13 when did you start
making videos art 9 the upfront works
for anybody who's trying to do the 2017
flip challenge $7.99 zero go and study
all the sold results of stuff that you
see so that you become educated and then
and go find it go ahead guys everybody
listen you don't have to be that well
like Americans especially Americans you
have [ __ ] around your house literally
clothes you don't wear anymore that can
start that capital this is the great
story keep going they quit his job we
can't the mall anybody that works at a
mall should quit right now and do the
2017 flip challenge now when I said quit
right now quit mentally do with this
dude dude and get some sort of base over
the next month and get the [ __ ] out of
there by December I've just become
completely and utterly obsessed with the
disruption of I basically think what's
happening in the creative production
world is what happened with uber and
Amazon what do I want to do I want to
let the market come to me I'll just
talking about Vayner productions our
production facility out in Long Island
City operations make it better make it
better what are we doing how are we
serving ourselves how we're gonna
service the outside market how we're
gonna produce original content like
[ __ ] just running an organ this is
just a meat and potatoes kind of episode
I hope run my business Manor X I got
this sauce setting
comfortable energy on my mind I've been
at the 7 carats and watch family fall
behind I'm losing touch with my baby I'm
probably good with the back you know if
we didn't think we were capable of
building one of the biggest firms built
on you know I think everybody talks the
same game so to me it's just gonna be
about execution just got off a phone
call with with some Vayner sports
business so working on that and now chef
I got a call with actually a former
contestants I'm playing of the apps I'm
not a I'm not a one-and-done guy you
know I'm in the business of people
forever looking at babban right now who
I love so much who's now in my heart and
family do I want him to be with me and
with me forever
yes do do I see scenario where tomorrow
or 7 years from now you may want to go
do something else sure but does that
mean that it's like done and see it
absolutely not always in the family
obviously people that are there you got
to treat a little bit better otherwise
everybody leave but that's that same way
I think about Boehner sports if a kid
signs with us he blows out his knee he's
in the Gary Vee Vayner sports business
he comes to work on Vayner I get him a
job and get him or her job like that's
what I'm about and then and that's what
I'm doing with those contestants and so
I like that you need to be you need to
be optimistic and patient and everything
will work out and if you're not it won't
the end you're [ __ ] 21 like I get
that you want to apply it like I want to
apply a to lack of patience bro wrap
your head around not giving a [ __ ] about
any advancement to you're 29 but then
every day trying to get better you will
[ __ ] win just close your eyes until
you're 29 patience man patience
everybody's looking up to audit
themselves where they are now
I promise you show me everybody you
think is fancy at 22 show me where they
were [ __ ] laying in their vomit in
their dorm room
you know what I mean like cool like I
get it like I mean just to don't vomit
in your dorm room and work everyday but
don't look at yourself at 21 you know
what I mean just close your eyes until
you're 29 just close your eyes until
you're 29 all your buddies for the next
10 years
we're gonna be judging themselves she in
here I'm gonna be looking around me like
where am i where am i everybody who's
trying to figure out where they are you
need to be thoughtful the people are
dwelling there's a big difference
between awareness and dwelling up be
aware of where you're at I'm always
aware where I'm at but I don't do well I
don't know obsess over and people that
do well in obsess and where they're at
in their 20s
close your eyes
[Music]
all right pretty shitty travel
experience flight had some issues
couldn't find our driver that cab
where's the [ __ ] at a time Jordan hates
wastin time I hate it more
work out next
[Music]
Lona Amsterdam right now looking forward
to it
having a huge problem with my TSA Tyler
C not happy I'm not fancy it's just
those minutes count so